this man defeated goldberg last night to
retain the championship and he is part
of
his next big event the shack bowl at the
super bowl
he's going to get out there and play
some football on team tampa bay with
nelly offset tim tebow and winnie harlow
how about that that's how shaq's gonna
roll coming up on super sunday
so anthony anderson's part of that team
too look at that
against team kansas city diplo ezekiel
elliott olivia culpo
cuevo stevo and the miz
i stopped listening after olivia coleman
okay sorry about that my bad
uh he is none other than wwe champion
wwe superstar drew mcintyre here on the
rich either show how are you drew
oh fantastic words thank you for having
me no thank you for coming on this show
so uh you dusted off goldberg last night
huh
well i certainly did i mean it was fast
it was frantic it was hard hitting
it might be 54 years old but my goodness
he still tackles
as hard as he did and there's a lot of
falcon days i took about three tackles
with the stomach my ribs are messed up
today but i'm still doing champion
that's right goldberg did have a cup of
coffee with the atlanta falcons back in
the day he did play some football
goldberg indeed i spoke to some of his
former teammates a few guys that used to
play against them and
they described him exactly how he is
still to this day a very
intense individual i mean i guess what
is it like for you
as you know and i i want to get into
your ascension into the person you are
today to look in the ring
and and that that that entrance last
night my gosh there was more fireworks
there than maybe we're going to see in
the super bowl coming up on sunday
but there's goldberg standing in the
ring waiting for you
what was that like for you true because
that is surreal
like i used to watch goldberg wrestle
when i was about 13
14 years old my brother and i biggest
wrestling fans in the world
and i never thought one day 20 plus
years later i mean
i thought i'd be able to be champion one
day that was my dream i never thought
i'd be wwe champion standing across the
ring
from bill goldberg in 2021 it's an
absolute fantasy situation for a
lifelong wrestling fan like myself
but as a professional you know i had to
be up
one of my former heroes as a kid so i
didn't feel so good about that but i'm
still wwe champion so i feel really good
about that i mean my gosh drew i mean
when mahomes looks across the sideline
and sees brady on sunday
you know he might have a similar moment
but he's going to have to take care of
brady like you took care of goldberg
that's that that's a fact you know what
i mean that's what happens in
competition
that's right so the current generation
has got to prove their worth and show
you know they can talk the the prior
generation that's what it's all about is
showing
you know i belong at the top and not
only could i hang with the previous
generation but
you know i could beat their butt to get
in the ring of your american tour so
um before the wwe you wrestled in the
xsbw do you want to describe what that
is
for those who might not know drama oh my
goodness oh you've really done your
research
the xsdw was my backyard
wrestling federation when i was a kid
for a lot of the the listeners out there
maybe wrestling with their friends in
the back garden had their own little
wrestling leagues i was one of them
my buddies and i would get together put
on our little wrestling matches filming
a camcorder
i think we were the greatest wrestlers
in the world i promised myself that food
would never see the light of day
somehow wwe got their hands on it and
they released it to the world what do
you mean they got there
so the camcorder footage of you
wrestling
in the extreme scottish backyard
wrestling that's the league correct
uh that if i'm not mistaken yeah that's
correct uh they got i mean
how'd they get their hands on this tape
drew how'd that happen
oh my good friend in scotland was the
holder of all that footage and uh he was
working directly with them
to get you know old pictures old video
clips of me for a documentary
little did i know it was going to
release everything to them
so how did you get your start how did
that happen how did how do you go from
your backyard
in scotland to what we're seeing today
drew
oh it was quite the journey when i
wanted to you know get to wwe i was from
i'm from here scotland
a country of five million people wwe is
a far away american thing that
nobody really from the uk had ever done
nobody from scotland had been signed to
wwe ever
and i was going to do whatever it took
to make my dream come true i had talked
about it my whole life i obsessed about
it my whole life i asked my mother to
let me go to the only wrestling school
in the uk
which was a 12-hour drive where i grew
up she said no
age 12 no age 13 age 14 and finally age
15.
she said okay if you're keeping constant
contact i talk to the promoter
you go with your buddy and you can start
the dream and i used to travel 24 hour
24 hour round trip just to learn uh you
know how to wrestle there was nothing in
scotland at the time and
that's what i did for the next year as
often as i could go as often as i could
afford i would travel down 24 hours to
that wrestling school
fly my craft started wrestling in the
independence started the modern day
scottish wrestling scene and the whole
time staying at school
and i went right through school all the
way to college got my degree in
criminology
and that very year my last year of
university i got signed to wwe 21 years
old the first ever scotsman signed
so if you didn't get that signature by
the wwe
what were you going to do with your
criminology degree drew mcintyre
as far as i'm concerned there's no plan
b okay my
criminology i've always been always been
interested in that area and i figured
man wrestling's filled with some really
weird people so i'm gonna be able to
profile them all and figure them all out
if i get the green criminology so it's
all part of the wrestling class
so there was no plan so i'm glad plan a
uh is unfolding
still to this day drew i'm pleased to
hear that so what's the craziest thing
you did
um either in your backyard or whatever
to to
that you wouldn't be able to attempt
even now um
as a wrestler what's the craziest thing
you've done
yeah i mean i used to jump off some high
play a wrestling ring just to clarify
was an old nasty ass mattress on on the
grass
and in scotland the weather's not good
so usually it was raining it was muddy
there was this nasty mattress
very unhygienic to think back on it i
used to jump off a very high places
and land on that very thin mattress if i
tried to do that today i would not get
back up if i
took a 16-17 foot full hunter mattress
i'd probably be getting
taken out on the stretch wwe champion
wwe superstar drew mcintyre here on the
rich eisen show
okay so you're going to participate in
the shack bowl uh coming up it's a
live three-hour pre-game broadcast
special at 3 eastern on super sunday
and uh and the crazy thing is that you
know there's no
there's no mattress here there's no
dusty or what do you got
nasty dusty old mattress here um he's
actually building a tent
you're going to be playing football in
it drew have you how much football
american football have you played
drew mcintyre oh i've played a whole
bunch of zero
i played a lot of football with like
soccer yeah you kick it with your feet
yes being from europe uh but no i've
never played
um american football before i've become
a big fan of it over the past couple
years very excited to see tampa bay
okay and finally we'll get some form and
be in the super bowl i've grown up in
campus my american hometown for 13 years
so i'm excited about that but the way i
figure it you know i'm representing team
tampa and the miz
the new superstars in kansas city i'm
sure he's played his whole life
yes but no matter what sport it is even
if i've never tried it i'm certainly
better than the miss
okay so so let's just let's walk through
it here
um uh do you want to i guess since you
said you played zero football
would you prefer to play defense or
offense which one would which one do you
think you can bring your best uh ability
to
drew let's walk through i feel like i
could do a little bit of both if i was
on the
defense you know get the opportunity to
run down some people from
the offense i get the opportunity to run
down some people i feel like i'll be
most effectively used the more damage i
can do to everyone being six foot five
270 pounds whenever i can crush some
people i'm having a good day
okay so let's just say drew uh drew
mcintyre you're lined up across from the
miz
and um you know you're getting the
football what happens next
i mean i'm just gonna run him down
anyway even if he's not directly in
front of me and it's gonna be the
football i'll go out of my way
and find him is run his ass down and
then i'll score a touchdown
do you have a celebration all all booked
you know that's that's part of the
the nfl experience is you you you score
and then you celebrate do you have
something like that
already lined up drew oh yeah oh yeah
yeah i've got a celebration i used to
use
in my soccer days when i was a kid
whenever i would score a goal the part
of my wrestling
match is whenever i get knocked down
towards the end i do a nip up you know
the move when you lie on your back and
jump to your feet
and at my sizes they're visually
impressive so i've got a little routine
of forward rolls into makeups and
whatnot i used to do when i was a kid so
it's been about 20 years but i'm still
going to break it out there go i mean
just it's like riding a bike i'm sure
celebrating a score it's like riding a
bike so were you six feet
absolutely a lot of people watching
that's what said that's right so were
you like when did you become six five
were you a soccer player i mean pardon
me a football player uh
at six five were you that tall yeah i
was
i've played it my entire life um and
everyone you know always recommended you
try rugby you're
literally twice the size of everyone and
you keep getting sent off the red card
you could
you know i was accidentally i'm doing
air quotations you know challenging
people too hard
i was generally twice the size of
everybody i am on the pitch
my very last game in football i had
started dressing at this point i got a
yellow card and then
i probably should have been sent off red
carded for the challenge for the yellow
card but for the second one someone
tried to run around me he ran into my
shoulder this wasn't my fault
knocked himself unconscious the referee
sent me off
i took off my shirt threw it at the
referee tried to fight the referee and
both managers had to drag me off the
pitch and that was the last game i
played 15 years old
so i figured maybe i should stop
pursuing this pursuing this wrestling
thing a little harder
yeah so i'm assuming you got red carded
drew
right you got red card yeah yeah yeah
that's why i tried to fight the ref i
was a little upset
and uh yeah as i said i took off my
shirt and threw it at him that's like
that's a
you know traditional wrestling move when
you're going to fight you take off the
shirt so you start fighting someone and
then at lunch for the
fully grown man referee at 15 years old
both managers and few players to drag me
off the bridge
and here we go and here we thought zidon
had the most dramatic send-off in the
history of the sport
um now i'm learning about the way drew
mcintyre walked away from uh from his
football our soccer
tj jefferson do you have a question for
wwe superstar
wwe champion drew mcintyre do you have
one tv i
have many okay you know if i'm gonna
give him one i want to say first of all
congrats to you drew as someone who's
followed your career for a while
it's great to see you get to the point
where you're at now
that's a it's a pretty awesome story um
you know you and i have a friend in
common
john pierre mourinho who used to be a
writer for wwe
yeah and he told me uh a little tidbit
and i want to see if you
remember this before the chosen one
gimmick they had another
gimmick uh laid out for you do you
remember
what that was something to do with being
a freaking male model
that's what he said he said you were you
were going to be a male model and the uh
the ramp was going to be your runway how
did you feel
about that i mean the chosen one was
obviously the better move
yeah i remember because i got told about
it i was about 260 at the time
you got this great idea for you you're
going to be a runway man
you're going to come out on a runway and
you're going to model all the latest
underpants or whatever
and that's going to be your gimmick
because you're the this model character
and like all my dreams
were just like crashed before my very
eyes but i couldn't
register on my face this is what it is a
huge opportunity i just naughty but
that's a great idea eventually you know
i had to cut down the 260 degree male
models i lost about 35 pounds to get the
abs in looking like an abercrombie and
fitch model you know a lot younger
looking at the time
basically a bit of a pretty boy i had
myself looking the part sat down with
vincent man he asked me my honest
opinion
of the character and i said you know
what sir if you guys know television
i'll make it work
he clearly saw that i did not like it at
all and said just go out there and be
yourself and if i'd already lost like 35
pounds
damn it i need to gain this weight back
i look like a male model but i'm going
to be a butt kicker
i'm glad that i never saw the light of
day though thank god so
literally the idea was to be a male
model
walking the runway to the ring that was
the initial
construct and then it morphed into the
chosen one which is
you would have chosen that i would very
much chose anything where i can just
kind of be myself the best characters
are an extension of your real
personality
right male model is nowhere close to
drew's real personality i was watching
youtube videos trying to figure out how
to walk
like a runway model and whatever i was
at my goodness this is
this is not the one for me
that's awesome now look at you drew
mcintyre
uh wwe superstar uh and
you know our show's on peacock which is
the home uh exclusive streaming home of
the wwe
and the us i hope this is the first of
many times that you you can come on this
show and we'll just keep
we'll just keep talking i really enjoyed
this conversation and i hope
you have a great shack bowl sir thank
you
now thank you both for having me it's
been a great chat like you say i'm
excited for the you know the partnership
on peacock becoming part of the nbc
family this is very exciting for us
and as soon as i get back on i'll give
you the review of the shack ball
uh ms will be in hospital we'll talk
about that and uh who knows
myself we got my team yeah yeah ten
people were good and he was pretty good
at throwing the ball so he can handle
the football part well yeah i'll handle
the running
thro doing the football part and i'll
handle running down people they're
unstoppable
well i i think hey look you could you
could uh block for nelly or
there is such an a a thing as an offset
offense
so we can you can actually have one
that'll be great it'll be terrific we
get drew back in there before
wrestlemania
i look forward to turning yeah there you
go you take care of yourself drew
mcintyre we'll see you on peacock uh
if not before uh the exclusive streaming
begins on march
18th with content and the fast lane
event first pay-per-view event on march
12th uh if not uh
then then uh just shortly right after on
this show we'll talk about it
thanks for the call oh absolutely thank
you guys take care you got it at d
mcintyre wwe on both twitter and
instagram that was
so much fun hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here